joining me now how cop chairwoman new
york congresswoman elise stefan at
congresswoman welcome to you
same question why do you think glenn
younkin succeeded where other
republicans have not
well number one glenn youngkin was an
exceptional candidate he was a positive
candidate who ran on issues that matter
to people's lives that mattered to the
people of virginia he made education a
priority which allowed him to grow
his base not just from registered
republicans but independents and
democrats who are fed up with the status
quo and our failing education system
particularly during covet he ran on the
economy making sure that virginia is
from his perspective the strongest state
in the nation to create jobs and grow
small businesses as they have struggled
when it comes to the recovery after
kovid and he ran as a big tent
republican not only did he do well in
rural communities which he won by 27
points trey but he also did well in the
suburbs
and he expanded our support among
hispanics african-americans suburban
women so this was about addition not
subtraction but this is an example where
candidates matter campaigns matter and
the issues that you run on and your
message matters on the flip side
democrats ran a campaign of the past it
was like they were relitigating the 2020
election terry mcauliffe talked more
about donald trump than he did frankly
about glenn younkin we remember at the
end that terry mcauliffe brought in
surrogates from the past including
former president barack obama the last
day was
his speaker from a former head of new
york state teachers unions so it was
very much a democratic campaign of the
past not of the future and of course the
results showed at the ballot box with
such an overwhelming win not just for
glenn younkin but the most diverse
ticket with winsome sears as the
lieutenant governor candidate
congresswoman republicans do not always
do well with women voters or young moms
and lucky for me you happen to be both
congratulations again on being a brand
new mom how can republicans not in
virginia take these lessons and apply
them in their own congressional
districts or even in a national race
i think bringing solutions is really
important and the issue of education i
can tell you as a new mom while sam is
only 10 weeks old i already think a lot
about making sure that he has the best
education possible republicans are the
party of parents democrats are the party
frankly of the failing status quo they
prioritize the teachers union instead of
the students parents and teachers this
race really showed that the republican
party is truly the party of parents and
i actually serve on the education
committee trey this is a growth
opportunity for us to share our message
in addition economic opportunity is huge
for working moms making sure that
there's good paying jobs and then i
would say the inflation is having an
impact up and down the ballot this is in
some ways
a judgment on joe biden's failed
economic policies as working moms as
women are seeing the inflated cost
whether it's when they go to the grocery
shore or even diapers i see those costs
going up month to month
you know congresswoman sometimes
winners
misread a narrow victory into a mandate
and every now and again people that lose
uh make a whole lot of excuses other
than the obvious you were you voted this
week after the virginia election results
did your colleagues on the other side of
the aisle learn anything or they really
plan to go bigger and faster despite
what happened in virginia
they are doubling down trey house
democrats are attempting to go bigger
and faster and more spending
we are already facing an economic crisis
whether it's the labor shortage coupled
with the inflation crisis democrats are
currently discussing a multi-trillion
dollar spending package the biggest
spending package in our nation's history
the largest tax hike in our nation's
history so they are doubling down on the
failed policies they did not learn the
lessons of virginia that it is not the
far left socialist ideas that voters are
looking for for voters are looking for
candidates that actually stand up for
the issues that matter to them that have
solutions when it comes to addressing
the economic crisis but instead nancy
pelosi is being controlled by the far
left
so in the coming weeks we will see as
they negotiate their trillion dollar tax
and spend package just how costly it
will be for the american people and
what's really important for the american
people to know is they wanted to vote on
that before a congressional budget
office score which means getting rid of
the washington speak that means that
they didn't actually know how costly it
would be to the taxpayers and how
significant the tax increases would be
the american people deserve to know the
cost the true cost of how many trillions
this is going to take over the next
decade
well congresswoman i hope that you are
actively involved with leader mccarthy
and others in setting the the agenda
picking the candidates for the fall that
has all of the makings of a successful
fall if republicans can avoid blowing it
and by the way you said sam is 10 weeks
old
yes
i'm sure he's already reading knowing
you as smart as you are my guest since
he's already reading thank you for
joining us on a sunday night i look
forward to visiting with you again
thank you trey we read every day
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else